I don't think that it's okay for a man  to go and get a side chick just because  of that what where's the Loyalty at like  when we get in a relationship I'm  getting in a relationship with you  thinking that you're gonna respect me be  loyal yeah but he he went in the  relationship thinking he was going to  get sex  yeah would you would you buy a car  without an engine no  so like what if you what if you bought a  car and then boom three months in the  engine's gone  he's like [ __ ] I gotta get to work why  ain't my car moving I've got a steering  wheel gears  I've got all everything why are my car  moving because women seem to forget that  the engine in the relationship is that  coochie that's what we go to work for  that's what we do 20 hours 40 hours 60  hours for so we can come home hear  nothing and be blessed with God's  greatest creation I